I was just like her to be remembered for
helping to open the Las Vegas Strip for
being someone that they used to Bill as
looks like Liz plays likely meaning
Liberace because she did look so much
like Elizabeth Taylor she was raised in
Cleveland Ohio as was my father
they married after World War two dad
discovered her in a lounge and said
that's the girl I'm gonna marry and she
was already engaged but he got her just
Hungarian determination
she just discovered that there wasn't a
lot of work options available in
Cleveland beyond the bars and lounges to
performance so she thought well let's go
west they decided hey listen let's try
this Las Vegas you know let's just go
give it a shot and they ended up staying
and she was hired and she would buy it
virtually every Hotel on the strip
played them all whether it be main room
or you know headline as a second act for
the headliners or in lounges she was
very very successful we had more
celebrities in and out of our house
eating dinner dad would make us
Hungarian paprikash she would play they
would all play and I don't know how our
neighbors put up with us basically
[Music]
she was asked by Pope Paul the second to
come to Rome and perform for him and
just just a kind good soul this is a
woman that would pray for anybody who
needed help six hours a day Frank
Sinatra asked her to join him on the
road and dad would have been included of
course she had just had me and said well
I can't because I just had a baby so
obviously family meant a lot more to her
than her career like she's mom why
didn't she just go he would spring
Sinatra would it got me a nanny
we miss her yeah greatly her star is in
front of the Paris hotel which is nice
that she was a casino legends Hall of
Fame so she's got that to add to her
glory and yes she is immortalized I'm so
when people walk by it they can see us
chemist composer and vocalist at cetera
we've lost an immeasurable amount of
talent in losing her he loved her
grandchildren
obviously she loved her family very very
much she's a very kind soul and she was
just extremely short narrative talented
you